Khiva only took four months from
contract execution till we started using
it the build-out and the other target
part of the building was about a year
the results that we've seen with Kiva is
one of the significant things as we
signed a contract in February and our
first order was in June which is unheard
of in the industry the other thing that
we've seen is in a relatively short
period of time not only were we able to
fleet up really fast but our
productivity over here is already twice
what it is in the traditional part of
the building our inventory accuracy we
think it's a hundred percent it's a
little early to tell until we do a lot
of cycle counts but we haven't seen any
defects yet and the other significant
thing that we've seen an improvement in
is safety we've had no incidents in the
Kiva area where we have anywhere from
two to three incidents a week or a month
in the traditional part of the building
one of the really nice things about Kiva
is that we were able to take the modular
design of the pod and adapt it to our
storage needs so one of our requirements
was storing our apparel flat so these
bins were custom designed just for us
for our needs and the nice thing about
that is I know as I would get into other
categories like baseball bats golf clubs
golf bags that we can equally design a
pod that will work for those storage
needs as well our orders there's 35,000
units a day are about one and a half
units per order on average about half
our orders are single orders about half
our orders are multi orders so we have a
sortation issue keep us a nice solution
for that because it doesn't add
complexity it takes complexity out of
the solution so one of the big benefits
is the worker is always on task they're
not standing around waiting for
something to happen so there's a queue
of work in front of the worker at all
time they're never really without
something to do now because we have a
traditional part of the building and we
have our new Kiva section the operators
actually kind of compete to see who can
work in Kiva they just love it over here
there's not as much walking it's it's a
lot quieter it's a peaceful environment
it's really a good system to work with
not only from all of those aspects but
also economically so we have about a 50%
reduction in labor on the outbound side
of the business our defect rate over
here is essentially zero
my name is Elizabeth Watkins I've worked
at Zappos for most two years now I
started out working in the static
shelving and it's it's an okay process
you take the shoes off hood line off the
put away line load them all onto a cart
hope they don't fall off walk them to a
location and hope there's room and then
you scan it and put it into location
doing put away in the static shelving
there's an awful lot of walking and you
spend all day just walking around
looking for a room to put away all your
shoes and apparel and things and at the
end of the day your feet just get really
tired I've been working the keys and
robot zone for about three months now
maybe a little longer and it's a really
good process I have been telling
everybody about the akiva robotic zone
area here at Zappos it's a lot easier on
your legs it's quieter it's faster I can
do twice the work using the robot system
and literally half the time I'm Felicia
Thurman and I've been here since June of
Oh eight I used to work in a different
warehouse and we use carousels sometimes
the carousels would mess up and we'd
have to call maintenance or we'd have to
walk home and it took a long time in
Kiva you stay in one spot and they come
to you a lot faster than walking so I
like the robots a lot better my name is
James Foster and I've worked here about
a year and a half it's very easy and
working with the robots because you know
they just bring it to you and you got
the laser to show you where you're
supposed to do everything so it's just a
lot of you know grab and put it where
it's supposed to pack it so it's it
seems very efficient the accuracy is
very good I haven't worked over here a
whole lot with the robots but the time
that I have has been very good I haven't
noticed a lot of problems or anything
with a conveyer process it's a little
tougher because there's a lot of things
can go wrong a lot of Jayne
and different things and you know the
system's not sinned and work to where
it's supposed to and I got to fix all
that so it's a little more frustrating
to work with over here with the robots
it seems to be a lot better quietness is
more enjoyable working with the robots
because you know you just after a while
you don't even realize working around
all the noise with the conveyors how
much it affects you you know you're
yelling at people trying to get a
message across over here you're just
talking and a normal voice you don't
have to miss understand what people are
saying so it's it's a more serene one of
the really big benefits that we've seen
with Kiva is the training cycle time
there's an in traditional part of
building when we bring in either new
people or seasonal help it takes about 4
days to get them up on tasks where
they're on the top of the learning curve
in here it's less than half a day the
storage density in this part of the
building where we've installed Kiva is
approximately eighty percent better than
our square footage utilization in the
traditional part of the building another
significant benefit that wasn't part of
the economic analysis but we found later
is that we're very much a service
company we want to get the order to the
customer as quickly as possible in our
traditional part of the building it can
go anywhere from 48 minutes at the
fastest to about three and a half hours
for a multi order over here it's about
12 minutes so that makes a huge impact
on our service to the customer in our
traditional part of the building just to
get it down to 48 minutes we had to
spend extra capital to get to that point
by improving the material handling
beyond what's normally available off the
shelf over here we were able to get it
down to 12 minutes without any extra
expense another big benefit we know
we'll get but we haven't quantified yet
is energy savings so this part of the
building still has some lights on not
very many as opposed to the other part
of the building but we're going to turn
these off and only have the area lit
where the people are another big
advantage is the original 416 thousand
square feet of the building we just
climate-controlled the entire thing for
human comfort and over here all we have
to do a spot pull the area so the energy
savings over here is
normos plus i have 23,000 feet of
conveyor that's running 24/7 over there
with 600 motors that are constantly
turning and I don't have that over here
another great benefit that we have is
that as the company has grown we're
getting into a lot more categories and
we're getting into jewelry and watches
and things like that that are highly
phil furball and the really nice benefit
to Kiva is that it you get natural
security because everywhere where the
pods are and the robots are it's a
personnel exclusion area so there should
never be a person in there the only
opportunity there ever be for shrinkage
is as the order comes to the picker so
our experience with Kiva during the
whole implementation contract
negotiations and everything have been
more of a partner than of a adversarial
vendor so it's been a fantastic
experience from a from a partnership
standpoint if I feel like the people who
keep our part of our company are part of
our family and not part of the other
defense as Zappos continues to grow we
think Kiva is going to be the solution
that we're going to use for a long time
we're already talking about the next
phase of it later this year and it will
it'll continue to grow and as we build a
new building I suspect it'll be a
hundred percent Kiva with no comparison